what you want to hit a rap about you
said politics is so general yeah now
what did you say
tweed jackets yeah amazing tweed jackets
you guys over here what your rap about
an umbrella beach prostate we're gonna
take prostate out of those three you
know umbrella fees yeah prostate said by
a man who's you sounded like you've had
several exams if I'm honest not that
your voice was high just you sound like
you know over boy and apparently that's
what happens I'm looking forward to it
so we have a prostate over that tweed
jacket the kind of this side of the
middle what you want a rap about parking
tickets and cool as to any rise of
parking tickets Christmas holidays
getting a parking ticket during the
Christmas holidays will combine them I
like that finally it's got the fourth
one the best suggestion I've ever had
was ninth century crop rotation so far
you are not troubling that this wedge
here Oasis as in the band Oasis as in
midnight don't say it to me I'm from
Manchester that's where that bands from
what's midnight or the Oasis it was a
song by whom
mold our is that net midnight other way
sis that's what we're gonna take I wish
we haven't but it's what we've got some
tweed jacket prostate getting a parking
ticket during the Christmas holidays and
away sis brackets midnight at Nueces
square brackets mold our we'll figure
out this then lovely people with a
comedy magic club to close out the show
son this spectacular freestyle rap made
up entirely on the spot based entirely
on those suggestions I do not worry is
not them anywhere near as embarrassingly
[ __ ] as you're expecting it to be so we
drop that beat let's show how we do and
the room is silent with excitement I
presume kick you off are right when I
say this war in the desert by Spike Owen
or wases little pool palm trees right at
the side check the watch on my wrist oh
it's that time midnight here I wanna get
a belly full the moon is full so I turn
into a wolf start lapping at the water a
- whoa I've been to midnight time here
who said so maybe someone called more
dour you can even bring a head no one
knows who the heck that is if there's a
singer here there'd be like no one's
even heard that song
it's from back in the day like way way
long let me move on yo I really can't
wait til a boy here get naughty prostate
exam and go to the doctor takes a shine
to me and then he loops up his finger
looking so shiny and puts it inside
behind me he says you'll feel a little
pressure yet not tiny anyone who's had
it there is high glass when you bend
over with the thumb up your ass probably
use the little one not the index doctor
prostate exam show respect who's next
align the guys out the door wanna get
touched in the prostate more apparent
yeah you know what I spilled the piece
is called the Mayo g-spot
we like it get a finger up papa we spray
like an oasis acres have come I am sorry
why did I do that image I come from the
UK a tiny little village got a village
green we're gonna succeed bacon jam
growing sweet and we all wear tweed God
the elbow pads they're on my sleeves so
much Harris Tweed you would not believe
Harris's the brand coming from Inger
lambda had to explain that so you'll
understand yeah tweed it really meant a
lot to you I wear it like I'm starring
the doctor who like an English professor
I get my reward I'm so assured with my
chalk on the blackboard last in fourth
one here I'm so glad we picked it
Christmas time get a parking ticket
I should afford getaway I'm like his
25th December Santa Claus is on his way
in the sleigh the rule of rude elves
there and not a real alpha parking
officer staying Chris give me a ran out
of time I say is there okay he chuckles
he says that's fine
but literally a fine like a park in the
tickets are there and he's getting
darkened and I stay now man
yeah wait this so what around the pocket
officer in that oasis yeah
[Applause]